hey sophia how are you hi morgan very
good here thank you how are you doing
i'm great how does it feel to have the
entire internet talking about you right
now
are they oh my goodness um
really exciting you know what it's just
so nice to see how much the fans are
engaging with the show
and um yeah it's
it's wonderful to see well you know
this is a very intense fandom uh when it
comes to anything marvel
and honestly the fans are so obsessed
with your character
there's just so much wonderful talk i'm
sure you've seen it on social media but
it's so fun scrolling through and seeing
how positive everyone's being
so let's talk about the scene with your
character sylvian loki that essentially
blew
up the internet um you know kate herron
the showrunner
uh she came out to confirm that loki is
indeed bisexual which is such a big deal
for the mcu
what was it like for you being a part of
that moment
um i mean we knew that it was important
when we were shooting it and we
we knew how important this particular
representation is
and that people have been waiting for it
for a long time and that the
you know the comics have touched on it
and even the norse mythology of this
character loki
um so it was just super important and
um it's so nice to see how happy people
are and how well received it's been
and kate has just done a fantastic job
of of making that episode um
and putting it out there you know when
you go into shooting a scene like that
uh did did you know it would be
that big like did you kind of have like
a an energy around you and tom
hiddleston knowing that that scene's
going to be
a very important scene i mean i remember
people talking about that it was going
to be an important scene but
i'm kind of new to all of this so i
don't think i realized
how big it was going to be and how many
people it would engage
um i'm quite grateful that i didn't know
otherwise i probably would have done the
scene completely differently and messed
it up
through nerves or something i would have
over thought exactly
would have really overacted it and got
all my lines wrong and
made a big old mess of it so i'm kind of
glad i didn't realize
um but yeah it's so so great to be a
part of i feel very proud
that's so cool and it must be really fun
for you you know it's fun for the fans
all the speculation as to your character
and the origin you know when you come
into a series like this
and you have the comics to back it up
who did you draw inspiration from when
it comes to this character
i mean the character is inspired and the
whole series is inspired by
the comics but it's you know it's a new
story in its own right and sylvie is a
new character
in her own right so you know i watched
all of tom's stuff as loki
and i researched you know
i researched a bunch of a bunch of like
mythology
and that kind of thing but to be honest
i i
i tried to create sylvie as a new
character
there are similarities and i think that
comes through in the writing
you know they're they're both
mischievous silvie has that chaotic
energy that loki has
she loves fighting and i think it really
comes out when she's fighting that she
loves a brawl and she loves beating
people up um
and that was really fun to play but you
know i think
still be silvie and and and it was
it was really fun to discover that yeah
is it refreshing too to play a character
who's kicking butt who's in flat shoes
not in high heels hairs up like getting
down to business
it was so nice and you know it was in
really important to me that i could move
around in the costume and not be wearing
high heels or like
ridiculous things like that because you
can't you can't walk in them never mind
kick butt in them so i worked really
closely with the with the costume
designer christine and why that and
she's she's just amazing she was
totally on board for everything and she
was like oh my god yes this has to be
really
easy to get on and off it has to be
really easy to move in so every fitting
i had and there were a lot of fittings
you know we were like getting down on
the floor and making sure i could move
my shoulders and my legs
and making sure i could have like a
harness underneath it comfortably
because for a lot of the um
stunts we were on wires and things like
for
crashing through the mine shaft ceiling
and things like that
so it was important that it all worked
and it was really practical and
comfortable
because it gets really hot in georgia as
well
what was the whole thing uh well i just
got the wrap but i just want to say
people are already talking about sylvie
having spin-off
shows or films with other mcu characters
people want to see a sylvian wanda
series is there anyone in the mcu that
you would love to
have silvie go up against other than
loki
can i say the hulk i'd love to see like
sylvie v the hulk that would be quite
fun
and mark ruffalo is amazing yeah okay
this needs to happen thank you so much
such a pleasure can't wait to see
all the episodes thank you thanks morgan
bye